hello and welcome to this video
production it was a friggin lawyer
playing one master Fight Club is a fight
club no name he's got a high rating but
I beating them two times no other
results but the two wins for me so get
another one of the closed with SWAT they
all play jump playing in chi go in style
why not definitely possible maybe 86
first they are kids all a big deal can
still think hello night to d5 is a is a
pin I know is it an annoying pen I
ambition be six I fear that was not
ideal but at least I played quickly at
least I played it quickly yeah so let's
see what fight club is doing symbols
that may be preparing before my night
only five really has done his job let's
go back he wants to at the end use the
square hmm that's not unreasonable
you should be three yeah white seems to
be a bit better in this pollution don't
particularly like it he's got in control
over d5 now and i don't i don't know if
i want to go g5 that's not a move that i
particularly enjoy to claim I mean we're
just kind of too friendly put I really
don't like this position at all this one
oh not nice yeah I if I was probably
naive move but I dislike my position
anyway they can we can win this now b5
but i actually don't mind that all that
much I mean having given the choice I
would rather not porn down but at least
I'm getting rid of his bishop that was
very strong and I get this diagonal open
so if I manage to unpin which will
probably happen quickly going to be six
or something I might have some action on
the long diagonal they don't get me
wrong this is not compensation or
anything but I think given given the
circumstances things are not that bad
after I've basically blundered to spawn
I mean so is there anything direct here
I don't know g5 I don't like g5 just
weakens too much yeah that was kind of
clear but I didn't know where else to
put the Queen
[Music]
yeah I thought some before here but
[Music]
doesn't do all that much
c4 doesn't work either maybe this one
yeah that's not bad that it's opening up
the the diagonal and 92 i have Knight to
e5 maybe at least his ideas coming into
play I don't know not at all okay so 97
okay I probably have to snatch this and
let's push yeah I've seen better
positions
but maybe it isn't isn't that easy d for
now looks looks normal
[Music]
can also take a chat forum is better in
in all cases almost I think so it's
there any trickery here can I do
something else then really I wonder if
rook c8 no actually not okay so i have
to take and he's got this strong deep on
not very nice so we're tube it okay if i
move the rogue actually what is he doing
next like here is called Queen to d7
okay he can check me here but you see
planning here Quincy six may mean but ok
let's let's go with this move and then
see I mean I'm still attacking c3 and
that potentially have Queen to a seven
yeah here i was thinking creature a
seven but he probably just plays rugby
seven anyway and I cannot take on f2
which is a real shame and I cannot trade
Queens obviously
check I'm dropping the night wow that's
good stuff okay wow what a bail and
resigned there are many problems with
those slow lines with with a 3 and C 3
and so on especially if the other guy
knows what is doing it doesn't really
matter all that much of its search we
were just like against anybody but
against GM's I have problems in those
line but don't don't really play it that
well and I think this is actually i'd
totally dislike that I allowed Bishop g5
in this pollution really dislike that
maybe I should have switched back to
some Bishop e7 stuff again here like not
this I never I never get anywhere near
using the bishop on g7 he just put
something on d5 and yeah thatthat's I
don't like it i mean the relief k 5 is
pretty terrible but I wasn't really sure
what to do the problem is that he would
always get a good get a good control
over d5 I sorry I got a message here
that completely distracted me yeah the
thing is if I play I mean e5 was bad but
just just to show the general idea after
he's taking he always has this this is
square which is which is annoying it can
even just take and an engine
play on that square like this click here
and he goes whatever may be in Queen to
be three okay that that's actually not
all that great but you can prepare it
maybe start with this I'm always a
little bit worse here because his
knights of valour in my bishop is not
too great Jen this is annoying really
yeah maybe I was too quick with this
decision but I fell out okay rook t6 is
actually ok for me interesting I didn't
didn't consider this more for ang five
as again I mean as I told you I felt
like this wasn't that bad but I played
it badly it seems this this this was
probably probably bad and i'm still not
so bad here with nie Dage filing before
amazing so all in all the terrible game
[Music]
yeah and this system this is this is
basically losing check you know when
kicking everyone already was winning but
this also wins like by a mile cheb just
bad him i didn't didn't play this
opening well i'm not good at all but
okay the way it turned out actually
wasn't that bad don't play something
like that Jim what can you do ok guys
thanks for watching